hey guys how's it going guess who's back
to LA back living in the house it's uh
Ryan and Matt yeah it's us it's actually
gonna be a creating stuff yeah will be
fun I doing tons of stuff we're going to
be making videos again we're gonna be
making a lot of cool stuff you know we
cook dinner last night together it was
really really awesome delicious it's not
to be back again because you know we
just kind of been alone or I've been
alone in this house and it's been like
really solitude to me whatever that's
called so lets us to selective
solicitation solid solitary it's been
it's been very it's you've been in solid
to spend very solitude so yeah so it's
really good to have my friends back
especially living together and keeping
the house a little more energetic and
keeping the work schedule like we got
the office setup that we're doing and so
we're going to be making tons of videos
but also this week I'm going to be
flying out for a make-a-wish Foundation
thing again like I have the opportunity
to make someone's wish they for some
reason decided that I'm their wish so
I'm super happy to be able to do that
and that happens later this week and we
have already been working on a sketch
well yes oh yeah yeah we came up with
this idea last night
and we really worked hard at it but no
no no don't spoil it oh yeah I was okay
I'll just show you guys because we
wanted to reintroduce like our work
ethic and what we do and like the art
that we put into the videos that we make
you know we want to show you guys right
now so here it is enjoy hello whoo right
we're not dying we're not done tell me
when you're ready
boys we've got a crisis the NSA has gone
rogue we need you to hack into the NSA
and then take over the NSA and then save
America and the world god bless
I'm ready yeah Matt hack to the [ __ ]
NSA we need to save the president the
Statue of Liberty is going on nuclear
downdraught okay yeah I got it it's
[ __ ] got it my kitties are ready for
you baby
I want it yes
yeah good job boys
uh-huh I miss god damn it Ryan and there
you have it wasn't it cool I love so
much I'm probably the most effort we've
put into a video since danger fiction
the hose oh god yeah yes that's been
really really taxing on us but we had a
ton of fun with it so we're glad were
you guys enjoyed it I expect a lot more
content of the same level of quality in
the near future not if I send the ball
reach oh yeah we'll say the market
really Adam we're going to get better as
time goes on I won't thank you like I
can't reach that bar that we set with
that I wish I was going to the vehicle
okay what we can do it's all about like
bringing other more talented people into
it yeah all we do because we've reached
our pinnacle of town before then
eventually you just need to move us out
and move other plate others yeah I'm
going to replace you
yeah yeah so look forward to that the
new Matt Ryan will be here in no time
cuz I am in Pat Ryan a chat yeah I would
like that very much so um thank you guys
so much we're gonna get back to work
here and as always we'll see you in the
next one bye
actions even be oh what's up guys